pone el acelerador a la lucha contra el
cambio climático durante la visita el
salón Internacional del automóvil de
Estados Unidos en Detroit el mandatario
anunció el primer desembolso para
habilitar unos 85.000 kilómetros del
Sistema Nacional de carreteras con
estaciones para recargar vehículos
eléctricos
saben que el gran viaje por carretera
americana va a estar totalmente
electrificado tanto si conduces de Costa
Costa por la i10 como por la i-75 aquí
en Michigan las estaciones de recarga
estarán en marcha y serán fáciles de
encontrar como son ahora las gasolineras
también vamos a invertir 7000 millones
de dólares para que las empresas
automovilísticas americanas dispongan de
las baterías y otros materiales críticos
que necesitan
en total vairen quiere instalar 500.000
cargadores en todo el país derivados de
la ley de infraestructura que da 5000
millones de dólares durante 5 años
Así que hoy me complace anunciar que
vamos a probar la financiación para que
los primeros 35 estados incluidos
Michigan construyen su propia
infraestructura de carga eléctrica en
todo su estado
en agosto de 2021 byden planteó como
objetivo que los vehículos eléctricos
representen el 50% de las ventas para
pero la industria automovilística teme
por los requisitos de abastecimiento de
la recién aprobada ley de reducción de
la inflación que obliga a los
fabricantes de automóviles a utilizar
baterías producidas en Norteamérica o de
países con los que Estados Unidos tiene
un acuerdo de libre comercio una norma
que según ellos podría ralentizar la
adopción generalizada de vehículos
eléctricos